everybody hi everyone Nathan mson I'm
the corporate
director Gareth James I'm Deputy Place
lead and the vice chair of this
committee
should should I continue yeah sorry my
name is fusle I'm counselor for bord and
word conservative
counselor my name is Jane broy and I'm a
timley North Ward counselor and here I
represent the liberal Democrats but I
also work in the NHS if that's useful
for people to
know hi I'm Caroline sidol I'm the
housing strategy and growth manager at
the
council morning everybody Li Liz mury
the tssp independ sh apologies a few
minutes
late morning everyone Tom Malone program
director of cost Health and Care joint
employment between the local Authority
and the locality team
nsgm warning Karen samples Director of
Education here on behalf of Jill
McGregor everyone I'm Emma mosy I'm the
senior policy officer at traffic
C morning Richard Royal corporate
director for place at Trafford Council
morning everybody there's a row of
Richards here isn't
there I'm Richard sping our managing
director of Trafford lco so I'm here as
myself and also representing KY Calvin
who as the chief
executive Alex Murray governance
officer good morning my name is Manish
I'm the associate medic director for
[Music]
TR J and clinical
[Laughter]
W Jane hes program manager from the
public health
Team good morning Jo chair Chief ex tra
leure morning all I'm Deb sson I'm a
consultant Public Health working at NHS
great
Manchester morning I'm Helen Collins
director public
Heth sorry morning everyone Simon wat
some consultant Public Health Manchester
Foundation
trust morning everyone I'm am Hinson I'm
one of the Public Health commission
managers in the
team Morning Joe briyan program manager
in the public health
Team thank you everybody um I'm just
going to do something a little bit
different with the um agenda and this is
Alex's uh last meeting with us for the
health and well-being board and he has
serviced us extremely well over the
period of time that I've been uh chair
of this chair of this board we would
just like to thank you all your hard
work um that you've put in for us and
you've sted me through many difficult
stor M so we would just like to give you
a little
[Applause]
gift
health and safety issue UN about
that thank you Alex you've been an
absolute
star so if we can with done attendance
is and you'll record any apologies for
us
Alex uh yes we got apologies from
Colette Rose Heather Fairfield Karina
car and Liz C
s the chief Council
[Music]
apologies thank you so if we can move on
to the minutes of the last um board
which was held on 15th of September does
anybody have
any comments
amendments matters
arising no thank you so agree those as
correct thank you and if we move on to
item three which is uh Declarations of
Interest so James do you want to do
yours
again I guess my Declaration of Interest
was I work for Manchester Foundation
trust at within Shore Hospital in the
diabetes
[Music]
Department um I'm the I'm an owner of a
social care company domiciliary care
company um we don't operate in Trafford
um but we might in the future as we
franchise the business so there's
nothing directly uh concerned with
Trafford but it's important me to know
that I do have a my own Dom care
business thank
you no further declarations thanks very
much so if we uh can move on to item
four which is the better care fund uh
the cour report so
over to Nathan look at me getting his
name right this time thanks chair and
weed a bit time for this agenda item
which is great so in terms of the um
paper that you've got in the park and
the Exel spreadsheet it's our
second return toest England for this
financial year the first um iteration
was to provide the initial capacity
plans and Nar
um and the second one is to go through
Q2 submission to go through
q1 I think it's important to note and
like to be aware that um the the
submission has been appraised by the um
Regional
PCF so this is our
Q2 and um we've had some really positive
feedback from that which is was most
and shows we are as a system a learning
system having some trations the first
submission um so the the Q2 um return
was submitted um within the national
deadline which is the
3 it covers two key areas performance
against our BCF metrics during q1 and as
I mentioned there sort of retrospective
view there are five um key metrics which
I'll prob bit more detail and second bit
was the revision of our capacity and
demand plans so in essence we put the
forecast in terms of our initial
submission where
we changes um all the detail is in the
Excel spreadsheet we tried to capture it
in the report recognizing that Exel
format isn't the most readily accessible
for for everyone
um so I will take us
through um item on the report to which
is around the back air from metrics so
as I mentioned there there are five core
metrics um and the first one is around
impant Hospital admissions for chronic
ulatory care sensitive
admissions um in terms of our
performance we have class thiss on track
and recognizing that we're a little bit
below the
trajectory but we know there are a
number of initiatives which have started
in traff or about to start in traid
which should assist us as we've go to
our Q3 few for submissions um so the
first one is around the introduction of
the traffic crisis response this is a
2hour response service which gives us
that extra capacity to to provide
immediate support for for people in the
community and this is something that
we've been lacking previously the the
hospital at home service is is something
an ambition of um mft to to move uh
people away from WS into care and
support from the clinical perspective in
their own home the the the program has
started rolling out in Manchester with a
plan
and to implement in traffic in G cost
and the reason for the delay the
tration chcken because the pr Serv first
to provide that bridge and
saf um in terms of the the second
metrics around percentage of people who
discharged from hospital to orary place
of residents though our actual
performance in q1 was ever slightly
below
expectations as noted in the reform the
Q2 data today shows a SL increase in the
um in the outter which means we we
should be on track I think it's
important to not it's reference
throughout the report the introduction
of the rapid
MDT for halfway through
discharges um this is um an approach
which piloted using Tech Goods fies um
earlier in the year about great success
in applying the multidisiplinary team
approach very early on in assessing
whether people would require long care
or not and the the
intervention though the pilot was quite
small in number demonstrated that were a
significant number of people who
potentially could be moved to halfway 2
or halfway one
um which is great for them because we
want people to go home but also good
from a public first perspective with
a expensive um that that activity in
terms of the um the rapid Mt has gone
for the pilot into the Main Street
Service which we've just launched last
month um in terms of the third metrics
around Emergency Hospital admissions
fors um we have reported On Track
Performance and though it's not
referenced in the report I think it's
important to know that there are some
good initiatives taking place in great
Manchester and implemented in traffic so
one of those is um Manchester University
have developed an app called the coku
app with keep on keep up which supports
strength balance in optimizing healthy
aging um and this this has been funded
through um digital digital grants
support to 500 people across Manchester
I'm pleased to say that as house
has pilot is taking part in this
initiative um we also recognize within
traffic need to to link up all the
various initiatives have lots of
initiatives and create a really good
offer um for the
people in terms of item four um rates of
permanent admissions to Residential Care
100,000 population this
is people um we're slightly off track on
this um we know that there has been
improvements in quity but our qu want
performance um has been kind of CAU up a
lot in in the um the panel of win from
previous year as previously referenced
the RT really D approach people on the
right
Pathways as the end of the year clearly
from a hospital perspective there is
emphasis on home
first
the
um the fifth metrics is around um the
proportion of all the people 865 or over
is still at1 days discharge
Hospital rehabitation
service um so we are currently a little
bit behind the F trajectory but broad be
on tracking we have a quite
comprehensive year offering in cha which
is a combination
services but we
recognize that in terms of the the
offer we need to be B more
D the out for so though we are getting
good percentages when
we possibly not all the people that
should
get
better in terms of the kind of second
part of the report which is
around kind of changes to any
assumptions I think it's important to
that when we
the
Q sorry
data we we didn't have the crisis resp
service
also in terms of the Home Market we we
know we've got a quite comprehensive
offer for car not struggling for
capacity we haven't P um but we are
going to be looking at
[Music]
theuring thank you
Nathan is there anything you no I don't
think thank you thank you for that and
anybody have any um questions or
comments on
um
presentation you
got let me just see what I'm going ask
youy so if we can then move on to the
recommendations and thank thank you for
that it was really helpful and it was
really helpful for you to go through
that so recommendation one and can we
look
to thank
you so if we can then move on to item
five which is um Health inequalities
update
andk morning you can
see and
as
yeah can I just ask that you all use
your microphones as well because while
you can be heard in here like the
recording doesn't pick it up if you're
not using your
mics it should automatically just
come
so I think while we wait for the tech to
to work if um my colleagues can
introduce themselves and set the scene a
bit and then we'll go through so the way
we' structured this is Deb is going to
talk to us about GM approach and Simon
is going to talk to us about nft
approach and then we're going to talk
about what we're going to do locally so
very much thinking about the actions
that we're going to put around health
and equalities traff
so so really welcome opportunity and to
to uh engage with the board members to
talk about how we um Can shape the
engagement draft which is out for
consultation at the moment around Fair
health for all and this was developed um
over the past 15 months alongside the
integrated care partnership strategy and
the priorities for coordinated action
there but it looks at how we can uh work
collaboratively across the city region
to address the root causes of Bill
health and um you create Greener fairer
more prosperous City region but also
look at how we can ensure that our
Health and Care Services are um
Equitable inclusive and you more
accessible for all as well as embedding
prevention equality sustainability the
the green plant into everything we do
and aligning those different agendas
looking at how we can tackle
discrimination injustices and prejudices
recognizing that that's a root cause of
some of our structure and inequalities
and our ability to to be healthy and
also shap in place and opportunities
that to meet help that so put this side
up to recognize that this work came from
the great work of chist great man from
the Independent inequalities commission
recognizing their
intersectionality um and very much we
need to understand that it's
inequalities in terms of people's
protected characteristics but which
influenced by the places where um the
opportunities they have in terms of
where they live where they work and
where they play and it's that
intersection which is important and this
work sort of took on the recommendations
of that report along
side
back moving on this um is a summary
which I'm going to talk to you through
of the
framework we started um if you look in
the bottom right hand recognizing that
it's at that neighborhood and county
level that we have that that strong
partnership work around action of what
we do in collaboratively to create Fair
Health but we need a framework which is
enabling that coordinated what can we do
at scale across great manchest but also
how can we uh support that culture
change that leadership uh by enabling
coordination across geography but also
across sectors so the first Workshop
where we propose the framework very much
wanted us to focus on the ways of
working the principles so I'm going to
talk you through some of those and then
look at how the framework is that
enabling function which is around pop
Health Management strategic intelligence
but also culture change leadership and
evidence and then how we are iteratively
developing those
tools so next slide so um hopefully when
you've read the the principles you will
will it will chime with um the values
within traffic and and we want we wanted
to um make sure that um something which
is a common language across great man
that can connect as world so very much
recognizing that we work with
communities for um proportionate
universalism is a term that um some of
the feedback we've had you know some
people find it hard but some people
really value it but I think the
description is helpful about you know
how we we are working with our
communities to co-design Universal
Services but with a scale and intensity
that's proportionate to the to the
levels that we need both geographically
and within different communities of
interest and identity the third one is
about making sure that actually this is
owned the equity agenda the inclusion
agenda and the sustainability agenda
we're joining up and we're making at
everybody's business it's not oh that's
the including team that lead that or
that's the Green Team about trying join
that up representation is recognizing
that um our role as employers is really
valuable in terms of making sure we have
a diverse work represent of our
community and the final one is around
our role as Anor institutions and an
Partnerships and Anor systems across GM
to actually shape the places that that
we our land and and our
opportun so um in the framework we
identified some high level 2030 outcome
targets which provide more detail than
the internet care partnership strategy
which looks at healthy life expectancy
this is the detail under um so we we
it's a further work is needed to
actually work with the intelligence
networks across the T localities to look
at how what's the trajectory for each
locality each neighborhood but also for
each community group and to us achieving
these 2030 targets and what's the logic
modeling and what are the output
indicators that we'd be expecting to
measure along the way and how are we
understanding and learning as a
network where there isn't progress as
planned or where there's greater
progress why what's different so that's
what we're really moving towards
understanding and learning as an
intelligent system about how our outcome
measures to our output Target
so welcome feedback on the high level
targets that we propos but recognizing
then it needs further work to develop
those
output please so put this in to
acknowledge the work that we the
framework supports in terms of our
social model for health that we're
proposing as part of the I strategy and
very much the uh the population health
approach you'll see in the buckets I've
put on on the left hand side it's
recognizing that what that means is
everything from addressing the root
causes of ill health and everything we
do in terms of our role as anchors um
but our policies and
our coordinated action to address the
commercial of Health create healthier
places all the way through to
comprehensive approaches detecting
respect factors like GM moving and our
GM wide mental wellbe um strategy to
name just a few and then um are further
work into prevention and early detection
in terms of people who are already
accessing care and ensuring that we take
a social model for health in terms of
how we go prevention those care Pathways
and how we're treating and managing ill
health and ensuring access Equitable
access so next
slide this is more it's the text around
that social model I thought it would be
helpful to put the social model in first
descriptively and then see I've talked
through some of those points in number
two already um but it's recognizing that
it's the breadth of everything we're
doing which is which the far FR it's
trying to join up these different
approaches and um those actions which
are part of the joint forward plan which
which describe what we're doing in a
coordinated way to deliver against these
um my uh the next slide shows the the
broad missions of the ICP strategy and
that's the what we're doing the F the
falth Thal framework is supporting the
how but I thought it was important to
put in the what as well so you can see
the context so if you move to the next
slide it reminds us that and the the the
joint for plan the as strategies is
built around this Mission approach which
looks at how we work differently with
communities to strengthen communities
and that's that's where our best start
work fits all the way through to um you
know ensuring that we have prevention
and early detection and a framework for
how we build prevention into all our
care
Pathways the third one is around good
work and picking up on the M
recommendation around you know good
employment the fourth one is very much
around um inclusive recovery and ACC
Equitable access is really important
there um the workforce um the fifth one
around Workforce again it picking up on
our rollers um on our anchor roles is
key and the final one in terms of
financial sustainability it's about the
governance for fair Health how we're
aligning the complexities of Greener
fair and more more inclusive but also
achieving
Financial so I wanted just to you
recognize it's 160 actions so I didn't I
couldn't cover them all but this just um
I name checks some of the broad areas
which align with the m recommendations
so ke one being best started life but
also making sure we're and having pocy
proof approaches and recognizing a
social model for health not just the
clinical as well as you know they're
working well and so you know I I do
encourage people to read the detail but
I just want to reference some of those
those um priorities and um this is the
last side of putting around ICT strategy
because um it's important that um this
is about coordinated action in terms of
how we work it's not so much what we do
it is what we do but it's how we're
doing it which is important so it's
ensuring that
we're understand everybody in the system
is taking that approach to to tackling
in policies about thinking about place
and people and thinking about
sustainability inclusion and equity and
joining that up so um
um this is part of this culture roacho
which is going around as a start the ICB
partners and our locality boards to look
at how we support this shifted towards a
social model um and the framework is
supporting some of the
action so next
slide this slide um just gives a summary
of the tools that we're starting to
co-design but very much it's I wanted to
emphasize that this is the beginning of
that Journey we really need a continuous
conversation between all the locality
Health anding boards and these the
central teams which are developing and
designing these tools and so the the
intelligence Hub we designed that as a
platform a web based platform that
signposts people out into our Tableau
dust so you can look at um at a
neighborhood level at a community of
interest level or at provider level or a
um a GM level and understand
inequalities and how that's changing
over time so the um it's you have to
register for it and we very much our our
vision is that all voluntary sector
Partners why the public sects and have
access to that dashboard so it would be
great to see how that's been promoted
through helping through traff sh we've
got a diverse representation you can
access that and one of the pieces of
work we're doing with 10gm is to scope
out capacity and capability within the
bcse sector to calate information and
intelligence around inequalities and how
we can um coordinate that in a routine
routinely upload that to the
intelligence Hub and both data and
insight because that's the other key
thing here it's about moving recognizing
that we need the qualitative Insight
from our Frontline staff but um from wi
Vol department so we're just about to do
a deep dive with dcsc sectors that work
with people mul disadvantage to look at
you know the opportunities that and
there's a wider survey out to broader
at so final um on the right hand side
there's the uh tool that is the academy
which is a website there should be links
in the slide but sorry apologies this is
an old slide Maybe but then I really
encourage people to look at that website
in its current version but with the view
that that's the space for us as a DM
system to share and learn about how we
create some fa health so um currently
it's um it has some videos and some
journeys of change some some case
studies from areas across Manchester so
be good to see how we're sharing the
Trafford learning within within that
website as well as um and offer to a
fellowship program which is available in
the first place to all um staff working
in the volun sector and quite the public
sector so NHS and and public authorities
who are passionate about creating fa
health and want to spend a
dedicated day a week on an idea in their
place that they could they could do and
they'll have supported ctd time
and um and then there's there's a a
leadership program that we're codesign
as well so really welcome your your
thoughts on um how this framework can
support and enable the work that
Trafford is doing but also how it can um
enable that coordinated action between
Trafford as m board and the wider the wi
the other health and the
W
to share the healthquality
yeah thanks uh thanks St and I One
introduced myself at the start but Simon
wats from Consulting Public Health at
mft so I um I'm a relatively new
appointment T the first time we had a
consultant Public Health at the trust so
I started in August um but I've been
there I was there last year as well as a
registra split between mft and MW so I
know the organization quite well despite
being relatively new in post um and I
just wanted to give you a bit of a
flavor really for some of the work we've
been doing around Health inequalities
over roughly the last 12 months
um and hopefully some of what I'll talk
about will link to what Debs has just
discussed and you think back to that
slide at the start with those five
principles one with people power hope
you'll see how some of what I'll
describe kind of aligns to that I
thought and this will be you might be
familiar with this this picture or this
slide and but I just I I thought I'd
include it because it's quite helpful
and it's it's how we kind of start to
talk about health inequalities at the
trust um in terms of you know what are
the drivers so 20 % of Health inequality
been caused by access to good quality
health care and that the fact that not
everyone has has got that and that's
different for different populations the
extent of Health inequality is been
determined by behaviors that people have
um so do you smoke do you drink what do
you eat those kind of
things but they're not independent of
the stuff above so if you look at the
top one socio economic Factor so what
kind of job do you have what kind of
what's your education that has an impact
on your health anyway but but definitely
links today's health behaviors and as
well they're not they're not independent
of each other and physical environment
what what's your housing like what's the
area around your home like so when when
we kind of describ this um you know as a
provider of healthcare like core
businesses they good quality access to
healthcare and it' be very easy for us
just to focus on that I think as part of
this health equalities work but you know
there's definitely opportunities and
this is what we're exploring and
starting to deliver through through the
work which I'll describe um in terms of
influenced some of those Health
behaviors so might have come across make
every contact count you know what what
is our you how can we build on that and
make sure that where we have got the
opportunity to influence behavior we are
doing um and you know socio economic
wise with the I think we're the biggest
employer in Greater Manchester how can
we provide those jobs in a way that you
know to underemployed communities
providing jobs locally I'll give a few
examples as we go through but huge role
there and if you think about health and
equalities the long term it is it is
good jobs it is education that will make
the difference so think we've got a role
in in all areas not just as a healthcare
delivery
organizations um just a little bit more
context say we um we had an away day um
earli in the year so in February that
brought together some of the senior
teams from across all the sites at mft
and to just focus a conversation around
Health inequalities so what do we mean
when we talk about health inequalities
is where do we see Health inequalities
in our practice um and what what are our
prior what should our priorities be as
an organization for for tackling those
that was a really good event and it g
gave us a bit of momentum really for
this work on the back of that um we've
developed a plan framework which you can
see below go through in a second but we
have got Health in's Group which is
chaired by the the group executive
medical director so really senior kind
of level uh who's the SRO for this work
um and as a result of the away Day in
February we've now got a health in
equalities lead at each of our main
sites so um we've got someone at at a
hospital site level who's who's you got
an interest and know responsibility
around this agenda which I think is
really important so for Trafford it's
cash you if you know cash and he's for
the whole we we've ensure Trafford Tre
footprint and this is the framework that
drops out of the um of the conversations
we've had over the last kind of 12
months almost and the away Day in
February so acknowledging that you know
20% of health care of Health in quarters
is driven by access to healthare we've
got two buckets of work there so the one
on the left embedding Equity into
services so that thing about
not offering the same to everyone
doesn't you doesn't necessarily help
from a health Nial point of view and
offering Pro provision of services based
on needs um you know in practice that
that can be quite difficult but but
we're trying to move towards that so
we've got some specific work which I'll
talk very briefly around in terms of
reviewing Pathways of care and how can
we make some of our services more
accessible for for some of our
population integrating care around the
needs of communities it's very much
around some of what B was talking around
in terms of people power and how can we
get better at working with residents
around how we develop our services and
some of the work that the lco is leading
around population Health
Management um our own staff we like I
said we're the biggest employer in great
Manchester if we we can improve the
health and M of our own staff that'll
have a big big impact on health
inequalities and some of the stuff that
that de's described around an anchor
organization and that I can touch on
that in a
second um conscious that's quite
theoretical what I've described so far
and and just give you some kind of
practical examples of of what we have
been doing so the first one in that
first bucket on on the previous diagram
in terms of embedding equity in Services
say we've we've developed a health
inequalities dashboard now which which
is essenti
like a health inequalities lens to some
of our operational data so you might be
familiar with like nonattendance DNA
rates did not attend rates for
appointments uh some of our Urgent Care
metrics like 4 Hour weight 12 hour
weight in AE we've now got the ability
to look at all that data through a
demographic lens so are certain people
waiting longer than others for their
elective care are they waiting longer in
A&E are they more or less likely to
attend an appointment or not based on
some of the demographics that's that's
then that data can then help us Target
some of our work so we're not you know
it helps Drive our Focus really rather
than it being less evidence and
database um lots of new technology in
the trust um so we've got a new
electronic patient record that offers
some opportunities to improve access for
certain groups um streamline some of our
processes but we're also very conscious
that that not everyone can access um
like you know devices and use apps so
there's some early work around digital
inclusion we are engaging with white
Partners around how we can work you work
with the system around and you know
training people you know teaching people
to use our app but also we need to get
to a point where you know people who
haven't got access to devices what what
was our support look like there so was a
work going on quite an early
stage um big piece of work across the
the whole trust really around health
literacy and what what I mean by that is
how we communicate about our services so
do the letters we write to patients make
sense um the average reading age in
Manchester across greater Manchester is
around eight or nine years old and if
you read some of our letters and patient
information leaflets they're often
pitched at quite a higher level to that
and and the language we using clinic and
on a ward might not necessarily always
land with patients so it's about trying
to rebase our communication and think
about how we can make it more um land
you land more appropriately with
patients and that that has impact that
has applications for Access for also
patient experience and safety as well so
significant piece of work there and I
mentioned um some pathway specific work
so one of the registrars who work with
is looking at the B councel pathway and
looking at where we see differential
like access so do we see different
population groups dropping out of that
pathway at different points and and
that'll help us drive some work to
improve
that um I've touched on some of the
integrating care around communities work
um
so that local approach to reducing
Health inequalities is very much the
population Health Management work being
led by the
LCA and yeah resident engagement and
codesign we do that at mft I think we
need we need to do more of it and then
that's that's kind of where we go in and
we've got some strategies and work going
on to kind of broaden that
that the next one there please thanks
um important I mean I'll kind of touch
on this I've the time we' we've as well
as the kind of clinical pathway work um
I mentioned work around wiing
determinance so thinking about education
employment um we've recently got um some
charitable funds to have some citizens
advice workers based in a number of our
sites and and that's something we're
hoping to broaden across the whole the
MFD footprint over the next year also so
helping patients with some of that
Financial inclusion issues that they
might be having um either as a result of
their Healthcare or that were there in
the first place place so if you can't
work because of your health um looking
at links to housing teams um we do see a
lot of patients with damper M coming
through the hospital how how can we
support those patients better and
connect them into support outside of the
hospital um huge amount of work going on
in the kind of anchor space so we've got
a Widing access
team mft
who who um work with kind of Partners in
the community to try and create you know
Target employment opportunities some our
local neighborhoods particularly those
areas where we're under employeed um we
need to scale that a bit more across the
trust so how can we make sure that all
our services all our teams are
recruiting in that way recruiting in a
way that you know reduces the barriers
for for some of our residents so got
some really good examples of that
recently with um taking recruitment out
into community centers so uh people kind
of want you know sign sign up for a time
they don't have to fill out a long job
application and then they get placed in
a job so we're doing some of that
scaling it is is a challenge but
something we want to do and I mentioned
staff staff heal and wellbeing in my
kind of earlier slide and again
something we've we've done recently is
um like staff health and well-being dat
where we get a number of providers in
staff can have a blood check a blood
pressure check a mini health check and
and talk to you know you things like
leisures facilities and and um employees
Support Services all provided in one
space on the same day so we we piloted
that about six weeks we're going to run
a series of events now over the next
year and for staff to try and give them
that access to help health support that
they might find difficult around their
busy
jobs um comes to time so I'll kind of
close there I think kind of put the a
the you know key enabler for this work
really is is around the leadership
around it and Def feel we've got strong
leadership um in the trust around Health
inequalities and it's it's gets a lot of
visibility the gief Z is you includes it
in a lot of what he talks about if
you've heard him speak um but there's
something about how we embed it in
everything we do so you know we need to
be making decisions that are always
conscious of of this issue and that's
something I'm I'm trying to influence at
trust level um but also how you make
this agenda real for Frontline staff so
you know actually if you're a
receptionist on a front desk somewhere
you've got a role in this agenda you
know do you use language that people can
understand do we code someone's
demographic data in our electronic
patient record so we can understand if
we are um seeing differential outcomes
of different groups and I see that as a
really key next step is how we take this
from being lots of projects to it being
kind of everyone's business on on the
front
line I I'll stop there and I move to
H thanks Simon thanks de so we've heard
about um we've heard about mfts this
this section as about how it flows into
Trafford and how we embed this into
traford really so um put quick reminder
on there but obviously I'm just going to
go through some of our key inequalities
again and why we're thinking about this
and how we look at system working for
traff and what the benefits and
considerations are so I think we used
this slide last time I'm not going to
question you I'm not going to make your
name inequalities against each of these
but it's just reminding us of what
inequalities are um I think we're moving
very much from that conceptual
discussion on inequalities to actually
make it practical who are and where are
our inequalities and traffic and how do
we address them another reminder is that
we still for Trafford even though we
perform really well in a number of
outcomes we still have some significant
inequalities and you can see there our
life expectancy is plateaued but we've
still got significant inequality between
our males and um our female populations
across Trafford which is is unacceptable
and we need to address them the other
thing I wanted to bring into this
conversation really is we're hearing at
the moment but how do we invest in
prevention how do we invest in
inequality and I think it's important
for us to recognize there's a huge
amount of benefits from investing um um
in different intentions and whether
that's about addressing the inequality
itself if we have a burough with health
inequality we never going to get that
thriving healthy population that we want
it's always judged on where our
inequality and where people have the
poorest Health um but also it's about
you know the return on investment so you
can see some of the stats there really
so for every one pound spent on alcohol
and there's a social return with three
kind what that means is both for health
services but also in terms of our
economy in terms of our education system
for our employment there's A3 pound
return and over 10 years alcohol every
one pound SP an alcohol can't say it
ironically um21 pounds within 10 years
so you know these are things that we
really need to consider as a system this
isn't about well it is about that's what
I would like to see far more investment
in prevention and our health INE
equality work but it may also be about
repurposing or looking at our finan
final flows more into the the early
prevention side rather than thinking
very much about crisis so I know um
physical activity is a good one there
with for every one pound spent on
physical activity3 p28 very specific
amount in it um return on investment and
um you know if we look at Public Health
interventions as a whole the average
return on investment for every one pound
spent on a public health intervention is
£14 so you know the a huge amount of
financial benefit as well as health gain
for our population it's really important
that we think about that particularly at
the moment when we are very much
thinking about the financial situation
for our
organizations so locally how can we
implement the GM uh work uh and I think
you know we're in a really good position
as a GM system at the moment aren't we
in terms of thinking about how we uh
tackle Health inequalities but also with
our colleagues in mft as well because
that for footprint flows across the hall
of Alor so um and I know that Joe spoke
to us at the last one about all the work
that we've done around healthy Liv so
the first step would be to do A needs
assessment to understand what are our
health inequalities in traffic how can
we articulate them and what evidence is
there about how we can actually affect
them so at the moment we're very much
thinking about what is public health
role do we do we try to push on a really
closed door that is never going to open
or do we need to think about where the
evidence sits and how we can move things
forward practically and that's what
we're thinking about as a team and
influencing the system to do and we have
to recognize obviously that for some
public health issues legislation is the
most powerful things if we think about
the smoking Bound for example um and the
impact that we saw from the back of that
so the other thing so we'd know what our
needs are then we would look at what our
activity is and across our team there's
I keep talking about our team but across
our team there's a huge amount work
going on I also recognizing Primary Care
in tlco and place across our um system
there's lots of work going on but
actually do we know what that looks like
collectively are there duplications are
the places that we could work a little
bit strongly together to improve and
that's that kind of mapping exercise
there and then it's comparing that what
are we doing with what our needs are and
then that will give us our gaps so
that's the kind of the the public health
framework that we would use which would
be influenced by the work from GM so how
do you promote system working and please
I don't want everyone to go oh God not
another group this won't be another
partnership where we sit around talking
what we're suggesting is the development
of a fa healthful traffic partnership so
this is where we pull down St GM and
across the patch and we work together to
to address as bit of housekeeping in a
way but actually work together develop
the oversight and influence the current
governance systems to address the
inequalities that we
identify and then how will we know we're
making a difference so the work that
Deb's talked about using the
intelligence from the um greater
Manchester Hub but
also from this work we would develop a
set of objectives so they would be
trafford's um Health INE equality
objective so for example we know that
people with serious mental illness and
Trafford experience much poor health and
people without serious mental illness so
one of our shared objectives might be
that we collect as a system address the
health inequalities experienced by
people with serious mental illness and
we know that smoking um is one of our
big contributor to that but there may be
other things around housing employment
for example that we could work together
to address um but also it's very much
around listening to the voice of our
residents and that's where the strength
of the neighborhood program comes in
unfortunately uh George isn't here today
but I know that he's a huge advocate for
that approach and I think that's
absolutely crucial to addressing
inequalities
uh within Trafford and then we have an
an annual review so we' be able to look
and measure and think about are we
actually addressing in the quties we
need to address and how then do we do we
shape our plan going
forward so establishing the Trafford um
partnership our Health traff Partnership
uh these are just some key bits really
so thinking about provides Focus we
would have the objectives here so the
objective obviously is to a system
approach to tackling Health inequalities
um and then talks through the kind of
steps that we would take but ultimately
the partnership would be accountable to
the health and wellbe board it wouldn't
be a partnership that does everything it
would be a partnership that that looks
and says right okay so we've clearly
gotten inequality here in I don't know
let's say smoking sensation sorry Aman
Joe but um and so we would take that we
would then take that into the tobacco
Alliance board and say right we want you
to address this how are you going to
address this and then it would be the
feedback loop into the partnership and
then we would annually or maybe more
than annually uh feedback into Health
wellbe Board so like this is what we're
doing so we actually have a shared
narrative and a shared understanding of
the Practical actions that are happening
within abora so that's how we envisage
this
working uh in terms of the influence
we've talked about GM influence but
obviously the MMA influence bit a MMA
fan girl I have to say although I did
meet him once but I couldn't speak I
became completely stru on which is
really embarrassing didn't know what
that was about but anyway uh but then
we've also got the faah health for
principle as well so we would blend
those into our approach in traid so we
have a really strong framework for
work so locally the strength for the
fair health for Trafford partnership
would be that the partnership supports a
needs-led system based approach to
mitigating Health inequalities at place
there's loads of words there that if you
know you look back at those thing
actually what does that mean but it is
about making it tangible and practical
and systemwide across Trafford we would
have a set of measurable Shar system
based objectives so we'd all be working
towards the same set of
inequalities um it it has a potential to
reduce duplication and improve the
effective use of resources but then we
would also have an annual process to
look back and say by this is great this
is really working or actually we're
missing this group here how do we bring
them in and that would allow us as a
system to think about that in that
way so um what we're asking the Health
mobing Board really today
um it's about that commitment so it's
about our partners participating and
setting monitoring reporting and metrics
embedding the action into that every day
business and that so when we're thinking
about the business at neighborhood at
service and at G level um capturing the
voice of residents and those people that
they work with as well so how do we hear
what is really impacting and I think
stuff that's come through mft around DNA
you know people want to access health
they want to get better but if they
can't get to their appointment because
they've got child care or they just
can't afford the bus fair then that in
itself is a huge kind of um inequality
isn't it and and I think we had a
discussion at our team meeting yesterday
about actually it's often surprising
that the health what drives Health
inequality isn't Health it is the you
know you can't leave your house because
you're afraid of being burgled for
example so you don't go to your
appointment that's an extreme example
but that's an example that we've heard
uh
previously and then it's just about that
communicating Health inequality so I
often talk about social workers so we
say to social workers oh you must do you
must do some work to address Health
inequalities but what does that actually
mean to them and it be um the
partnership will allow us to have a
shared narrative that that is practical
for our Frontline workers so that's the
benefits and that's the commitment that
we we're asking from colleagues so the
next steps for this work the traed work
is to agree the proposed approach and to
agree the accountability governance and
Leadership and to identify membership
but also we need to acknowledge the
questions and and and asks that have
come from our GM colleagues and mft
colleagues as well so thank you I think
we're all help in equality
down
thanks thank you Helen and and Simon for
that presentation and really really
interesting work that we're looking to
do and I think that it's a really good
idea that we're going to have to Fair
Health attrative Partnership going
forward we think that you know we've
talked about being a marment region for
ages now and it feels like actually
we're moving there now so I think it's
really really good work and if we don't
have Equity of access for all our
residents you know whatever we say and
do with this sort of forum is never
going to be delivered on the on the um
on the ground so I think that some of
the stuff that you saying around the
region reading age of of residents
across the the 10 authorities have been
between eight and N I think that's
something that I have fun about nearly
every meeting that we have you know if
we if we don't understand it how how
those people understand it so I think
that's um really good that we're going
to be looking at doing those sort of
things does does anybody else have any
yet
Jan
sorry okay so I cast myself as a
Frontline worker on three
fronts um I'm an NHS Frontline worker
I'm front line worker in my ward as a
local counselor and I'm a sort of
Frontline carer for two family members
who access Services who've both got
significant needs my two questions are I
was inspired to hear about the work
that's going on to kind of Reach people
who are Frontline because I think that's
where the operational Drive happens
because it is very impressive when you
hear what trafford's doing and the drive
behind the what was saying at the
meeting here but I I'm still not
convinced that that's actually filtering
through to the front line I mean
particular examples I think the links
between the Mental Health Trust aren't
particularly good at the front line um
the links between physical health and uh
mental health because of the difference
of
organizations they often there's often
complete mismatches which leave a a
vulnerable person who's got challenging
mental health difficulties or learning
difficulties they haven't a clue how to
make the services work for them I still
think there's a lot more that could be
done by because I can see the
wastefulness of what happens for those
individuals so that's my question to
Public Health my question to mft
declaring an interest as an employee
mft um I can see within mft because it's
an organization that's come together
with lots of kind of individual trusts
with their own history and their own
sort of operational programs within the
services is there are inequalities
within those services in itself so for
example the service you might get at MRI
might be different from the service you
get at withen Shore might be different
from the service you get at Trafford so
across mft just as somebody who's worked
for the organization out two and a half
years I think the vision and values are
very good and they do Drive staff to
good behaviors but I still think there
is so much inequality in the actual
services that are delivered and I see
that just from my eyes on the front
line um yeah I mean I'll come back on
the the second Point first I think I
think you're right um so
we I may mention like the the dashboard
I think we did an exercise recently
where we looked at all the DNA rates and
the elective weights across all the
sites to see different brots are
disproportionately affected by
demographic um the waiting time we
didn't see that but we did see like what
you've described in that you the same
service that provided at different sites
we saw different waiting times and
there's a bit of a legacy of maybe of
how things used to be provided and then
it's come together but but actually
those waiting really you should there
should be one there across and you wait
the same amount of time but that's just
one example as they'll be you know
different levels other than waiting list
there'll be other levels of services
service provision that varies so I think
I think you're right and I know there's
work going on to try and measure that in
a bit more of a consistent way so this
concept of like a single service
provision across mft um but we need to
measure that and see make sure it's
having in practice but
knowledge um in terms of mental health
what I say we we had the first movement
with the all age Mental Health Group
last week which is bringing together the
system around mental health um I
acknowledged that there are still
significant challenges around um some of
the inequalities that are service users
Ed and that's demonstrated in our health
and in our outcomes locally as well
we've now have um CLA Robson who's our
Public Health mental health lead within
our team who's working really closely
with Rick um and I think this will be
something that comes through that work
program in terms of how we address the
actual kind of experiences of our
patients and ensure that there is um
equity in in Access and care don't know
if Nathan wanted to mention anything on
that sorry Nathan
[Music]
one
of that meeting was just the scale of
one the offer but to the challenge how
we bring quite disperate systems
together so I
[Music]
think
kind of L for line because we talk a
good game about how team
is thank you chair um got a few
questions maybe they will or will not be
appropriate for answering in this forum
or might be an email down line um I
wanted to ask uh what Constitution
specialist Dimension care
um providers excuse me and how that's
determined and how can somebody say we
are a specialist diens care provider who
decides that anybody can say it um
another one was was with regards through
inequalities um during covid there was
more online
appointments even online face Toof face
the a GP that I use use an app where I
could just send a message and say about
this issue or whatever
and it worked fantastically well I don't
know why that was ceased um but I'd like
to ask whether there's
any um desire to go through more online
app based uh Service delivery to address
U Financial inequalities Geographic
inequalities people who live in more
rural and semi- rural areas those who
struggle to get to appointments or
whatever uh and also I feel like this
would um relieve some pressure on GPS
for example who need to see people face
to face and perhaps half people they see
could just be an online chat or whatever
um another thing is I just wanted to get
a bit understanding of how um the new
prescribing pharmacists thing is is
happening in the area whether we're
going to enable pharmacists to prescribe
to take some pressure of GPS Etc um
fourthly a AI excuse me I know this is
quite a bit forward thinking um but is
there any
have there be any discussions about Ai
and how that might be introduced to
local services and how that might affect
local Service delivery in the future
because there is something that's
obviously going to happen and is
happening and there will be AI doctors
out there and consultants and whatever
so trying to get an understanding of
where we're up to with that as well
thank
you lot of questions there I think that
issue around AI I think that's something
that we all need to be keeping our eye
on isn't it because I think that you
know the there just have been a recent
um meeting for um the Prime Minister and
others around Ai and I'm not suggesting
that it is AI that we're actually using
in our um Adult Services we are using
some sort of like robotic stuff and we
launched that I think that we raised
that um exec on um Wednesday so I think
that it might be good for you to get
involved that work that we're looking at
and you as well Jay I think that you
know we've got this something like robot
it's a genie it's absolutely brilliant
um so I just think that that' be really
interesting for you but are you able to
take yeah whoever wants to take them
take
them I can come in on maybe two and four
but I suppose from more of a secondary
care perspective I know your point on on
mine felt like it was quite Primary Care
Focus but I mean I mentioned the my mft
app I think in my input and so that our
kind of patient portal we are
increasingly able to do more through
that so um with piloting um some
Crushers for example around like so if
you on an msk pathway musos Leal pathway
you might have back pain or something
like that trying to collect some
information ahead of appointments to
kind of almost triage people so rather
than being on a waiting list for however
long and then seeing someone able to get
some of that information while you're on
the waiting list and then to hour you
coly so actually you might not need to
see the doctor you might be able to go
through a preferral into meure for
example and so that's an example where
we're trying to use some other Tech but
it's it is still relatively new so it's
been in for a year now and that might
sound a long time but like the kind of
mobilization period is quite long and
and there's lots of opportunities to do
more so change appointments through the
app and get short notice appointments
through the app that kind of things but
very conscious that not everyone can
access the app so we just need to be
like keep that in mind the whole time
because what we don't want to do is the
people who use it and can access it be
somebody they get a brilliant service we
want to make sure that gets a billion
service so that Gap doesn't get bigger
it gets smaller and and then the fourth
Point around AI just a very like kind of
small example of something we're doing
and again it's linked to the new system
we've got it does give us
some access to some AI kind of
functionality so one of the things we Le
we we' kind of working on a minute we've
not gone live with is um you can use AI
to help us predict who might not be able
to attend an appointment um based on
some demographic factors and their
appointment history in the past
and that can help us um Target some like
prevention work so for example if you
could identify the top 20 people you
might be less like to attend you could
give them a call and say are you aware
the appointment can can you attend and
remove it to help you to join so there
there one small inome
for just on Community Pharmacy you're
quite right both locally and nationally
there's a real drive for Community
Pharmacy to do more to take pressure off
other areas of the health system and one
example that we've got launching I think
it's on the 1 of December is where
pharmacies will now have the ability to
be able to do repeat um contraceptive
skill pill prescriptions and so that
will take that'll help to reduce the
pressure however locally we're really
aware that there's lots of pressures on
Community Pharmacy so the health and
well-being board some members and
obviously it's open to anyone else who
wants to come along in January we're
setting up a meeting to speak with our
local pharmaceutical committee around
the pressures and you may have seen in
the press press Only Yesterday the stuff
around their contract and their
financing that's just been negotiated uh
so we want to meet with them to
understand some of those pressures and
how we might be able to support them
more effectively to be able to do more
in
Trafford yeah thanks I was just going to
come in on the AI point because I hadn't
articulated it prop but with the
intelligence Hub we now have a data
warehouse where we've got all the prare
GP and wion SE records linked with the
SE care which has only recently had the
IG approved in the last few weeks so now
the there's a massive art of the
possible with this data robot that we've
got to
alternate but if if you think for
example in the past if we' asked GP
practices who of your who of your
patients that has diabetes is not coming
in for their annual blood check to see
how well it's monitored they wouldn't be
it wouldn't be an easy question that you
could ask some people with some Paces
could do it but others couldn't now we
can create an algorithm once in GM and
we can do it across all G practices and
we can look at Trends we can say by
ethnicity by age but and we can push it
back to all the practices and say this
person living at this address you need
to ring because I haven't been in a for
appointment so it's huge what we can do
with the data now and the work that you
were saying um
s is happening in mft because it there
hasn't been this data Rob on this this
inter IG agreement now we can not just
do it for mft but we do it once GM and
either mft use it or The Neighborhood
use it or so that's where we're looking
at greater efficiencies in how we use AI
as a system and how we have one data
warehouse for that and and my final
comment was about you know the point
around the pharmacy and the prescription
it's one examp example of how within
primary care but not thinking just dpy
don't we have to think wide the public
sex Poli SE as part of that access to
health and well-being support I think
the primary care blueprint is a really
good um overarching blueprint in terms
of that shift to how we can work
together in thinking right right person
right place and not having you know
thinking about working with communities
have pathway
to see wears the right care wear you
know and digital inclusion is part of
that but um so I think the primary care
blueprint is a good read that gives that
overarching view of that um how we're
Shifting the models in primary
care Joe did you want come in on this
point
um you want in on this point the um yeah
so I can pick up the uh the question
around general practice
thank you for question I think general
practice has has
evolved uh so general practice has has
has has has evolved over the years and
has compl Leed and Bounds from where it
was perhaps 20 25 years ago so Jal
practice has kind of um electronic
software that supports in medical
documentation but in terms of access so
certainly after Co General practice
offers a range of methodologies
including online telephone videos and
also of face to face and I think the
digital question is is an interesting
one because whilst there is a large
cohort of patients that would value um a
digital mechanism um there are those
patients who are not digitally enabled
as yet we need to make sure that we have
access to those so there's there's a bit
of a hybrid res but often I think
general practice is as as well as the
rest of the system is under extreme
pressure as as you'll probably know and
I think digital is a way to kind of help
mitigate some of that probably not the
only solution and I would probably add
to that is that dependence on digital
while it's useful we've had cases across
Manchester where when the software goes
down and doesn't work then I introduces
a lot of problems as well so it's it's
about having that flexibility to manage
patient care in a safe way in terms of
the AI question it's a good one and I
think anecdotally I think there's a lot
of work going on around um radiology and
kind of looking at CH XR to CT stands
but I
think it's got to be safe for me I think
it's we're we're going to be relying on
a system that is not safe then we're
going to have lots of risks that's going
to be introduced in the system so I
think I know there's a lot of research
behind it and power is going to be a
mechanism in the future but hope that
helps do do you want to on
the yeah I I'll do my best it's a really
good question quite quite a technical
one so I'll just give it a little bit of
an
overw so I mean in terms of specialist
demena provision in home environment I
mean there's a there's a number of
factors that would would come into play
here one's around the Staffing model and
the deployment staff generally more
intensive in terms of Staffing
requirement um also
quite obviously the try a really
fundament on around training of staff
and their their skill levels um the
physical
environment is also important um because
you know the new ad build homes tend to
be designed specifically from a person
perspective certainly person with
dementia low of the old
establishments clearly you know family
homes have been develop
the care setting and and the wi kind of
offer as well in terms of any top MDT
support but I think one of the most
fundamental things is it is the need to
really co-design the office so give the
example of
how specialisten Provisions the whole
service offer and through design for a
particular Dimension unit was done in
conjunction with c
and ICB Commissioners and I think that
joint working between the the public and
private sector is really important and
because we do quite often see um offers
to develop care settings in in this B
indeed elsewh in the country where it's
kind of an identic out box software and
I think it's really important to reflect
the the local community and the
GL um but I'm sure I can give you a much
more technical answer but I probably
have to be outside the
meeting thank you Nathan and I've got a
question comment from G Joe oh so you
okay
Joe yeah thank you should you the last
one uh so couple of questions so in
terms of um the GM partnership first
brilliant that the Data Insights
continuing to
develop um just thinking about that
cross collaboration and from GM we often
see the GM picture and then we'll see
each of the
localities um if we take Trafford as
example there lots of roads where one
side's Trafford one side's Manchester
and I think if we really want to drill
into that collaboration and start making
a difference in the way in which we work
I think we need to think about where the
inequalities are and then think about
how that's presented and not be
restricted to
boundaries um next next one on the um
Manchester partnership I'm brilliant
with the um fairer Health
principles um and noticing in the people
power um it's got the the trust and the
collaboration um one of the strong
outcomes that's come from the poverty
truth work um is that the trust started
um and then that led to collaboration
but the outcome for the individual to
make a change whether that was learning
to read or write whether that was doing
some physical activity came from
confidence so I know you've got it in
your sort of um Mission strategies but I
think I think there's something in there
around that recognizing in that behavior
change that it's Confidence from that
individual that brings about a
change um next one love with mft in
terms of looking at your staff um and
well-being I just wondered if you
developed a dashboard for your staff to
actually sort of measure um what that
shift in health and wellbeing might look
like and I think there's a number of
organizations that are looking to do
that and maybe it's an opportunity to
share and think at scale if we all
perhaps looked at our own workforces
that were connected with this work how
we might be able to to be more
collaborative um and then the last one
Helen thank you on the fairer Health
Partnership um and if George was that
here now how does that sort of work on
the areas of inequality in those
neighborhoods that we want to make sure
in that fairer partnership we get the
focus that's needed in an in an area as
well as those
inequalities I don't want to put
pressure on people we are running over
time so if we can just well if we can
just answer I think it'd be really
helpful for the board to hear some of
those answers and I think that obviously
we're going to be bringing this back to
further board so to you all again thank
you
so just on uh the neighborhoods and how
we do that is we've already been having
these discussions with George and
colleagues we have um identified Public
Health officers for each of
neighborhoods but also I sit on the
neighborhood Steering group as is
Richard and Nathan so I think there's a
natural kind of alignment to the work
here but it is you know we need to
address them at place that's where the
inequalities are and that's why we need
to know what those inequalities are
because what you know the inequality we
identif right might affect North more
than it affects South for example and
it's just thinking how we adapt to
address them in that way so the
neighborhood work fits perfectly with
this it needs to be layered with the
fair of Health form partnership I
think and so we do thanks to the point
on the the workforce dashboard we we we
are developing a dashboard that looks
talks to some of what I described in
terms of where do we recruit across the
city and where a different popular
relationss less or more likely to be
recruited but I think it's a great idea
about potentially incorporating some
helping more in there so good L on
that Richard thank you I'll be very
quick because um you know it's off is a
subject people are passionate about I
just I'm just going to give three really
quick examples of positive things we are
doing because it's quite easy to get
lost in a kind of esoteric discussion
around this isn't it so in terms of just
some examples for people here about
things that have happened in Trafford
talks about the neighborhood plan so
we've got a plan in place now for each
of the four neighborhoods that's owned
by the community that's focused on
health inequalities in traford which is
a significant step forward which we've
done over the last six months um couple
of examples from North Trafford uh we
have done a focused piece of work around
vaccine hesitancy in school children
Mandy nolles who led that is one of our
fantastic um School nurses was nominated
for ban nurse of the Year nationally as
part of doing that work and also we had
a recruitment event at Limelight focused
on admin vacancies that we had and we
focused on people who had were protected
characteristics who've been out of work
for over 12 months and we filled all our
vacancies with the recruitment day that
we had was over 10 posts they've all
completed their probation periods as
well so I think some of it's just about
thinking differently but there's lots of
examples of some great work as well so I
just want to give some positive news
amongst the fact that it's difficult
isn't it which we
know I think that's um really helpful
Richard I think it's rounded off this
topic really nicely so if we can move to
the recommendations one to two on the uh
report is everybody happy to agree this
way
forward thank you we can now move on to
item six
[Music]
morning everyone um also just while this
is loading James are beating Richards 42
so four four but so now there's only one
Richard left as
[Music]
well okay uh so this is just an update
um on the healthy weights Deep dive
priorities that were identified going
back probably 18 months um or so now um
just a little bit of context some um
more recent data so prevalence of excess
weight in adults is now six just under
62% so similar to the England um figure
which is not 6.8 there's a number
missing out out of there um that equates
to around just short of 110,000 adults
in traford who are overweight or very
overweight so just to give an idea of
this the scale um National child
measurement program data from this last
uh Academic Year shows that again 17.8%
children Age 4 to5 are overweight are
very overweight better than England and
same at age 10 to 11 better than England
but also put into context that's still
at years six that's still over a third
of our children um with excess weight it
also masks that there are um significant
internal inequality inequalities so
children living in the most deprived um
quintile nearly twice as likely to be
overweight or very overweight compared
to those in the least deprived areas so
in our most deprived communities it's
getting up to nearly half of our
children at year six are um experiencing
excess weight so we know it's a complex
system of factors that drive excess
weight um we've got huge numbers of
people living with excess weight we're
not going to solve this just by looking
at individual Behavior change programs
we need to focus on the social economic
environmental determinants and also some
of the commercial determinants of health
so what different Industries do to try
and influence the behaviors and the
choices that all of us
make so um hopefully this is relatively
clear it looks really complex but
actually it's not so on the left you've
got the how effective types of
interventions are in addressing healthy
weight the ones at the top the green are
the most effective going down to the red
that are the least effective on the
right are different types of
interventions ranked by heal at the top
are the ones that are perceived to be by
the public to be the most effective and
at the bottom the ones that are
perceived to be the least effective and
what you can see is that the ones that
the evidence tells us are most effective
are the ones that the public think are
least effective so we've already got a
little bit of a challenge there
So based on what we know is more
effective um at the Deep dive we
identified four priorities um looking at
um council's advertising policy looking
at our local planning and policy um
School food and vending as well so I'm
just going to give an update on those
four and happy to take questions at the
end of that so the first one was around
advertising policy um we know that
reducing exposure to adverts of products
or services that are harmful to health
can reduce consumption and use industry
would not spend millions and millions of
pounds on Advertising if it didn't work
and we've already got an advertising
policy within the council that restricts
some harmful products and services so
for example can't advertize smoking
tobacco vaping um however foods that are
high in fat salt and sugar alcohol and
gambling are permitted so we've got some
uh some work to do there um we know that
there are health and economic benefits
from restricting advancement of um I'm
going to call them hfss Foods so foods
that high in fat salt and sugar um and
we also know the evidence tells us that
advertising of these Foods is
disproportionately targeted at our most
disadvantaged communities so it's
already compounding those Health
inequalities um bit of national and
Regional context so at least 10 local
authorities have already implemented
hfss advertising restrictions lots more
are in the process I will also say they
not all in London I think there's about
four or five London um authorities and
the rest are spread around the country
um some have also widened the scope of
their um advertising policy to include
all harmful products and if the reframed
them as non-harmful advertising policies
um at a GM level the directors of Public
Health have identified commercial
determinants of Health as a priority
which should facilitate this kind of
wider GM progress on this so we've got
advertising sites that are on Council
land that we can control through our
contracts tfgm um manage all the bus
stop advertising and then there's
obviously advertisings also on um
private land there is obviously a
perception that there's a risk of loss
of Revenue that if Trafford implemented
this policy that somebody would just go
over the road and advertise their
products in Manchester so this kind of
wider GM Focus helps us reduce that
perceived risk of loss of Revenue and I
say perceived because the evidence from
the um transport blundon hfss
advertising ban is that it actually
doesn't impact on revenue and so that
kind of perceived risk of loss should be
mitigated there so in terms of progress
to date we've had discussions with
internal colleagues um it's within the
place directorate that hold the um
contract we've had discussions around
the policy and the um type of product
and the contracts which um we hold in
the council we've also done some mapping
and reviews of council own and private
sites to look at the scope because
actually if between Council owned and
tfdm sites we actually still only
control 20% of all the Outdoor
Advertising we need to look at what the
impact of a change in policy would be so
we're reviewing actually how much P what
how many private sites there are um that
we have less or zero chance of
influencing um we're also working
closely with their potential evaluation
partner um based in the Northeast who
has offered to support us and any
potential GM work in terms of the
research and evaluation of this policy
so that would potentially be a huge
increase in our um scope to review if
and when we Implement such a
policy so the next steps um to review
the contracts for in terms of the sales
and marketing of advertising space we
need to identify the terms and
conditions and whether they are able to
be changed or whether we need to wait
for contract ends renewals extension
dates um we also need to try and get
some more data from the um companies
that we commissioned to deliver these um
the sales and marketing of the
advertising space to see if we can get
some data on the type of products that
are currently advertised um and we also
need to look at the social value
commitments and deliverables that have
been identified through those contracts
and actually whether we've got any scope
to um make changes to our policy through
that route um and then we need to
complete the Baseline assessment um of
advertisements and break them down into
what how much is um on Council land how
much on tfdm and how much is private
ownership as I've mentioned
before okay so the second priority that
was identified through the Deep dive was
around local planning and policy um so
this was really around the local plan
which is a kind of strategic document
around development and planning within
the burough and um any um impact that we
could make to ensure that Planning and
Development um supports improved health
and wellbe and reduced inequalities um
so so far we've consulted with our
colleagues in strategic planning to
understand the timelines and the
processes it's a very lengthy process um
and we also now need to understand how
we can influence the content to ensure
that there are sufficient levers within
that plan um to make sure that basically
there are hooks within the plan that if
we want to we can um hang different um
supplementary planning documents or
different um policy on if that's the
route that we want to take so if we do
take this route then we need to consider
both um some of the things that have
been done previously around um the
planning um approvals for hot food
takeaways and where they are located but
also around um active and sustainable
travel the Trafford design guide if it's
adopted probably covers most of the
active and sustainable travel but we
need to then look at um whether we want
to have supplementary planning documents
alongside the local plan around um
things like hot food takeaways so our
next steps are to assemble and review
the evidence on the effectiveness of
spds um we need to look at the current
food and planning landscape and actually
whether spds are a sufficient Leever to
influence consumption we know that more
recently we've got dark kitchens so
those that aren't customer facing they
just Supply they're basically a takeaway
they don't have a front door and they
just Supply via online ordering like
delivery and Uber so it might be that
supplementary planning document isn't
the way forward because actually all of
you know majority of the foods coming
out through dark kitchen so we've got
some reviewing to do there we need to
review the wording of the draft local
plan when it comes out for consultation
which I think will be um going to go for
mid next year based on the conversations
we've had with strategic planning and
just look whether we feel health and
wellbeing elements within the plan are
strong enough um and then depending on
the route we take we may or may not look
to develop some draft proposals for um
supplementary planning
documents Okay the third um priority was
around school food and ensuring the
school food standards are met across
Trafford and potentially developing a
set of enhanced School food standards
for Trafford um and looking to implement
kind of pilot with at least one school
it's going to be a slight
longer piece of work this the national
scho school food standards not robustly
inspected they're not universally
adhered to although they are mandatory
for most schools um food standards
agency delivering a pilot where
environmental health officers will
monitor adherence to the school food
standards alongside Their Food hygiene
visits and so there's some learning to
come out of that piece of work as well
um there's some thoughts that the school
food standards actually aren't very
robust in themselves as as well which is
why we want to look at both parts of it
is are they being adhered to but
actually are they fit for purpose as
well in terms of progress uh we've done
a rapid evidence review on school Food
and Health um there's some emerging
evidence that children in England have I
think it's up to 70% of the food that
they get at school is ultr processed
food which is linked with a wide range
of um health
concerns um and that in some places
children potentially have 30% so around
a third of all their calories come
through the food that they eat at school
um we've worked with colleagues in
environmental health and Trafford
services for education to understand the
potential scope obviously each school is
responsible for um Contracting their own
catering Supply what we do have is our
internal and catering service who's
who who serve probably around 90% of the
primary school so we've got some scope
in there we've um worked with colleagues
from Blackpool Council who part of the
FSA pilot and using looking at um
adherence to the F School food standards
and they've been really helpful in
sharing their experience um so far and
then we've supported and guided a traine
environmental health officer who's in
the final year of her um degree and her
dissertation is going to be on school
food and the school food standards so
we've managed to we're going to get some
um of that localized data as well and
then finally we've got a small budget
within the public health Team to look at
engag some external expertise to
progress the priority and build capacity
with Trafford within Trafford so we can
maintain any progress longer term
because it's all very well going in and
doing kind of a one-off bit of research
but actually we need to kind of build
capacity and understand how we can make
changes to school food move and maintain
them moving forward so next steps on
this one uh to continue to support our
training environmental health officer
around the research project commissioned
some specialist support to undertake a
bit Ro review and feasibility of what we
can do um and then that will um um
determine our next
steps okay the final one is around
vending so the final um priority was to
develop a policy statement on vending
machines and to implement this across
health and Mobility board partner
organizations um ideally by mid next
year but in line or in line with
contract renewals so
um not made as much progress this one
these are all quite meaty pieces of work
and we've started our EV evidence review
on healthy vending so far it's it it
does look like it has an impact on
people's consumption um and I will also
flag up that Trafford Leisure are
leading the way because I don't think
Joe would let me sit back down if I
didn't mention it um so each time the
each of our L senses as they're
undergoing refurbishment as they're
reopening they are reopening without
vending machines and my understanding is
that nobody's really battered an eyelid
so so that's a really positive example
that actually if you kind of factor in
alongside other changes that it can be
quite a kind of a a lowrisk option okay
so next steps just to complete our
evidence review review our vending
machine provision across the council
estate to start with then look at Health
wellbe invol partner organizations and
then look at a kind of draft policy
template that um organizations can use
um to change develop their own in
policy so just to sum up these are all
medium to long-term um actions that will
have which we hope will have a
population level impact on health
outcomes and health inequalities
relating to excess weight we're going to
continue leading this work it's taking a
lot of work building relationships
working collaboratively with Partners
across the system and to address the
obesogenic
environment
that's thank you jayen that was a real
whistle whistle tops to
that paper and I know that people may
have questions on this but we are
actually running out of time and I want
to be able to give other people an
opportunity to speak to their papers so
Jane is it okay if we take questions and
get them to if we get if people send
questions to Jane and then we include
them in the
minutes would that be all right J
absolutely thank you so much no problem
so um if we can um approve the
recommendations to note the reports and
to support the for points going forward
would that we agree thank you
very and yes if we can move on to
stopping the start great Amy thank
[Music]
you all right thank
you
[Music]
see
just plug in the HDMI lead should do
[Music]
it
hi everyone um so I'm IM hodkinson I'm
the public health commissioning manager
here at Trafford um I've been to the
health wellbeing board in relation to
alcohol before but um I've recently been
appointed to take up the smoking area of
work so you have to bear with me um and
new still learning um but it's really
exciting there's loads of things going
on there's real B in the kind of Public
Health smoking World um so I come today
to talk about stopping the SP stopping
the start which is government's um new
announcements that come out I've only
got 10 minutes and there's low to go
through um but I'll go through it as
quickly as I can just so we stop talk of
everything that's going on um so this
side has kind of been provided by our
colleagues at Ohad and it's just a
really good summary in the four
different sections
um so the first one is a smoke
freenation um so the government plans to
bring forward legislation making it an
offense to sell tobacco products to
anyone born or after 1 of January 2009
year on year so that basically means
that anyone who's currently 14 or
younger will never a never be able to be
legally sold cigarettes um the second
element is around helping smokers quick
so there's increased investment um
coming to local authorities around your
local shop smoking Services um there's
also additional funding in terms of
national campaigns um that going to roll
out and also some funding towards the
swap to stop scheme which we did speak
about um last time Joe presented at the
health and wellbeing board which is
basically the government are ring our um
e cigarettes to put within your stop
smoking services and the third element
is around the new vaping measures um so
this particular looks at when we think
of children children young people in the
reports there of them vaping um and kind
of balancing that um the evidence at the
moment suggests that you cigarettes are
really beneficial quit aid for those
that are currently smoking kind of
balancing that in terms of not getting
people that don't smoke to Bab and
particular children young people who are
more vulnerable so there's a currently
consultation out at the moment and I'll
go into more detailed consultation
towards the end but that looks at
elements like restricting baked flavors
and regulation of the packaging product
presentation the point of display um
the Restriction around disposable Vapes
um and also looking at other nicotine
products so for example um nicotine
pouches as well and last but not least
there's support um for enforcement so
additional um investment coming to
enforcement agencies there um they're
helping to put out a new elicit strategy
from hmrc in Border Force which will
establish a multi- agency elicit tobacco
task force they're going to introduce
new powers I hope to introduce new
powers to local authorities um to
enforce um age of sale legislation so
kind of on the spot finds and they're
also going to enhance some of the online
age verifications so that um it's better
kind of restrict um underage sales that
are going on online so what does this
mean for traffic um so in terms of the
swap to start scheme we put in an
application with our colleagues in
Greater Manchester through the Smoke
free app so basically that means traffic
residents can access the smoke fre you
app as they can do already but as part
of that they can also order a vape which
will be delivered to their home address
and then they will receive personalized
behavioral support to help them quit
smoking through the app um with the use
of that VAP as well so that's something
we've put in hopefully gets approved we
don't have any reason um be the stage
why it wouldn't so fingers crossed all
that goes through um in terms of the
funding towards local Authority stop
smoking Services um Traer will be
awarded um
28,41 in grant funding um over five
years starting from next financial year
there are some conditions to that grant
funding so for example um can't C you
existence um smoking budget you kind of
have to continue with everything that's
happening already um we do have to
report back quarterly in terms of our
spend and what our outcomes look like
and in terms of what we can spend the
money on there is a little bit of
flexibility in terms of your
commissioning capacity to kind of manage
this um the extra projects that you're
going to put forward with the funding um
there's also some capacity to do some
local campaigns the investment that's
been suggested as I mentioned earli was
for the national stuff but a little bit
can be put towards the local campaigns
if wanted to do something locally but
the majority of it should be rent
specifically for smoking sociation so
basically to get people to quit smoking
um and I've put on here a slide where
I've tried to kind of summarize our
initial thoughts so this is just a draft
at the minute but we've gone on based
off our traffic needs assessment um
which Joe presented about last time
we've got we've looked at that we've
spoken to our tobacco Alliance so since
the last um health and wellbe board
we now have our action plan for the
tobacco Alliance um our vision strategy
Etc and so we've kind of looked at that
um to think how best C utilizes grant
money for the tra of residents um and
we're looking at a targeted approach so
just to kind of explain a side those
that are in green are what we already
have in Trafford as part of our core
budget so for the general population and
we have smoking sociation through GPS
and phaces and then on the targeted
level we have um the Blue Sky service
which deliver targeted support for those
with service mental illness um and we've
also commissioned early young people and
Family Service to deliver targeted STS
and support to young people and families
um in Orange there in development we've
got social housing because we're
currently in conversation with our um
Partners at great places social housing
um to deliver somewhere there so we're
in conversation with them around that
swap to stop ski getting the roll out of
the app within the services and then the
blue is everything else um so from the
needs assessment from the tobacco
Alliance and in terms of the general
population there was a really strong
theme around our coms and marketing and
TR residents knowing where to go and the
services knowing where people to sign
post to so considering little investment
there but the majority um on targeted
groups where have got higher risk of
smoking prevalence um hoping that will
reduce inequalities and I think follows
on quite nicely from the conversations
that have already been held this morning
morning so for example our routine of
manual workers and LGBT got carers fire
rescue service pleasure Services drug
dependency homelessness and deprived
community so that's just some examples
at the moment um that we're looking at
and I think very well prepared quite
looky we did our needs assessment when
we did it kind of put put us in great um
preparation for where we need to be now
in terms of getting this roled out we
have commissioned some um smoking train
in um so some of that was held earlier
this week around brief interventions and
then earlier this month the kind of
two-day practitioner course and
obviously we'll get more of that out as
we progress this further as well um and
then last but not least what does this
mean for Trafford um so an addition to
that also means that we have the
opportunity to express our local views
um via the national consultation um so
there is a live consultation out at the
minute um and that's live until the 6th
of December um so we'll the consultation
looks at the different areas within the
announcements so creating smoke
regeneration tackling newth vaping and
enforcement um we have approach Partners
already so we've kind of spoken to
Children's social care we've spoken to
colleagues in education school health um
early break trading standards um also
local businesses in Trafford as well um
through the inclusive Economist team to
gather their feedback um and in our
draft response so far um we have put
forward our agreement to the suggested
change in legislation that government
are proposing and we've highlighted the
risk of harm to traffic young people and
particular those where they've had the
adulated evapes which have resulted in a
effects um the difficulties that our
education School colleagues are facing
in terms of restricting The Vape use um
with the people um we've put forward
comments around agreeing to regulate the
packaging and product presentation so
they're not marketed to young people um
and they St marketed is a nicotine
delivery device um for adults who want
to quit smoking um and we've also been
quite balanced in kind of putting in
there that um although we are for that
there is the potential risk there of the
consequence to drive illegal um tobacco
sales which may impact the most
vulnerable in our society so we trying
to be balanced with our approach um but
hopefully the um additional investment
with enforcement what enforcement will
help mitigate some of that um so that
is a very quick rst St talk from May um
in terms of next steps we're just asking
for the Health wellbe members to agree
to our targeted approach for how we
spend that grant funding um if any
health wellbeing board members do have
any feedback you would like to include
in the National consultation please do
let us know before the end of the month
so we can compile it all together ready
for the six of December
um and then if there's any other key
stakeholders that we've currently not um
shared the national consultation with
please let us know we can send that out
we're sending it to people so that
people can do their own response if they
wanted to or if they wanted to feed it
back to us and we can send that across
behalf of our traffic response and and
mindful of time I didn't put my email
address on there so people know where to
shout so thank thank you am that again
was a whistle top Whistle Stop talk say
it today so um I know that people may
have questions around this and I think
it's a really important subject and I
know that um Council are going to uh
look at a motion around vaping uh next
week so I think it's you know it's a
really important topic for us and but if
we can have questions or comments to Amy
directly that we can include in the
minutes and obviously I'm sure you'll be
coming back to see us and on another day
so if we can agree the next steps of
points one to three is that okay with
everybody thank you
and sorry Tom we haven't left you very
much time um if we can go over to item
eight Tom thank you um I'll keep this
real suing because we have had previous
conversations here about the locality
plan refreshing that commitment from the
health and wellbe what is is really
welcome and this was just just try to
set out a few more practical steps uh
next steps of of how we will do that and
the time frames with the process but
that detail is contained within the
slide deck so hopefully people will have
uh had chance to read that through
reintroduce myself actually so Tom
Malone a joint appointment between the
local Authority and n
sgm and so we as I said we have
committed to refreshing our locality
plan for a number of reasons there's an
absolute plethora of them in one of the
slides in the back um and it feels like
the re really the right time to do that
on the back of a greater Manchester
integrated care partnership strategy
excuse me um and an Associated fiveyear
joint for plan of which the health
inequalities conversation resonate
throughout um so it's a really opportune
moment and I suppose the question I want
to to land with the health and
well-being board today um and one
comment and ask really is that that the
health and well-being board connects
into that work over the coming months
and there will be a piece of work
between now and March to the
pre-election period where we will start
some um codesign the first iteration of
that plan and then some further work
over the summer to think about how we
get to a more sort of four to five year
locality plan as well so the initial
piece of work describ will be about the
next 12 months 24 25 um with a with a
commitment to thinking about what the
longer term aspirations for for Trafford
as a Health and Care System um so the
health and wellbe board and the health
and well-being strategy most importantly
can't get lost within that refresh of
the locality plan it can't be a standard
Health and Care document um that's
focused on NHS it has to be that
holistic approach to improving health
and well-being all of which we've heard
about today in the other items and so
that's the that that's my my point I
wanted to make and then just to really
um give people the opportunity to engage
in that on a practical basis we have set
up or um we are about to set up I think
the email's landed while I've been
sitting here um to form a very small but
succinct and and hopefully powerful
steer so we're going to have a strategy
group um over the course of something
now um we commencing 27th of November
it's going to meet for the first time
and we already have really good
representation from all of the key
Partners in this room today GP ball for
example Etc um if you want to come and
be part of that group we' be really
really welcome to receive that support
and help and guidance given that there
may be different partners in this room
today than than some that have uh come
from the locality board so I'll leave it
at that conscious of
time thank you and again that was a fast
fast um update for us and so if people
are interested in being part of the
strategy board if you can let on no I
think that's really important that we
have as many contributors as we possibly
can and to that so thank you and if we
can just agree the recommendations at
point one and two um for the minutes
thank you sorry we couldn't give you
time for any questions I'm sorry so
um over to you Emma on the real living
wage thank
you
Qui great and so the report on the role
of wage is included in the document so
you can read through there for a bit
more
information um so as of January 2023
Council are now paying the RO of wage to
all their employees we managed to
achieve our accreditation in March um
which is accredited by the real living
wage um
Foundation which is a great success for
the council we're very pleased about um
as a result of that accreditation it
means that
320 school and local Authority staff are
now receiving a pay Rise um when that
pay rise happen in January that was
meant that their wages went up to 1090
per
hour so um a few weeks ago the real
living wage um rate was announced for
the year which happens every single year
it increased by 10% to 12 um traffic
Council um as part of the accreditation
have until May to Institute that pay
rise for all of our staff and we're
hoping that'll happen a lot sooner than
May and that's something that HR are
working on at the
moment so as part of the accreditation
um we have agreed to a project plan over
three years which means that all our
contractors who are employed for a
certain um for two hours a week for 8
consective weeks have to be paid the
real wage and so that's something we're
working towards at the moment AC with
procurement our accreditation also means
that the majority of local authorities
in GM are now credited six out of 10 um
so that means we're a step closer to gr
Manchester becoming the first um region
to pay all of its employees real living
wage we're not there yet but that's our
aim um this appr presentation is a
crucial part of our commitment um
joining crisis and our commitments on
poverty and it's also a key part of our
accreditation as uh good employment
Charter which we achieved in June um
after fulfilling lots of criteria but
this is one of
them and so yeah that's just a little
bit about the way that curement think
included it in our tender documents to
ensure that we um achieve that project
plan within three years making sure all
our contractors are pay Rel
wage so yeah that's just a little bit of
an update um we're very proud that we
now have the
citation thank you I think that's been
really helpful and I think that you know
across GM for us to be um you know six
out of 10 now of the local authorities
are real living wage employers I think
that's really good progress and I think
you know if we're talking about being a
m um region I think that's you know
lifting people AP is going to be one of
those things and we should be paying the
rating for the job so I think that's I
think that's a really really excellent
um way moving move forward for us and
does anybody have any questions that
they' like to ask Emma okay Phil doesn't
necessarily have to be answered now with
time restraints um but I think it's
great that the real living wage has been
implemented but I just wanted to ask how
um those that the council contract with
how we're ensuring that they any
subcontractors Etc are also providing
real living wage and the council aren't
just Contracting out the obligation of
paying a real living range
thanks I can email you more information
on that but part of that project plan
over those three years is all about
making sure that yeah it's in contract
as well the foundation's very clear that
you don't yeah push your
responsibilities elsewhere so I can send
you bit more information about that
thanks I think yeah it's part of our
procurement process isn't it that when
we are procuring with people they
will employees so um if we can move to
the recommendations and um ask um you
know people can can can those that um
those organizations around the table can
you and consider applying for the real
living wage accreditation and obviously
can people support Trafford council's
ongoing commitment to the real living
wage
accreditation thank
you so that brings us to the end and
we're looking a bit thinner now aren't
we well thanks everybody and I know that
it's there's so much information um that
comes to the board and it's really
important that we're you know that we
are able to um listen to some of those
pieces of work and and I just feel
really bad that Tom every time we come
to board you are the one that has to
sort of like cram everything in in um in
five minutes so I think that you know
next time the board meets I would like
to see Tom's item first on that on the
that he does actually get some feedback
from people on the day Tom says the
agendas and I just like to thank you
again i' just like to thank you again
Alex for all the support that you've
given the board all the support that
you've given me over the last um five
years that I've been been on on this
board and a counselor so you will be a
loss and um good luck to your future and
thank you everybody for today and I'm
sure there's some people sat to the left
of me who now May need to go and eat a
sandwich the Bell have been
rumbling thank
you